[Music]
okay so everybody ready for the next one
let's go
let's go with the next game
1835 for chow chow
uh
let's play something offbeat
let's play something offbeat i want to
play something offbeat
um i kinda wanna play d5 here i wanna
play the elephant gambit
or the stafford shall we see how the
staffer turns out at this level we've
played the stafford once let's play the
staffer to get let's play the stafford
let's play this down let's see how it
turns out against an 1800 let's play the
stafford
oh my gosh
god dang knight c3 come on this should
be criminalized it should be illegally
criminalized
um every time i say the the uh the s
word
uh people don't go into it now i will
say that in my
recollection
you can play d5 in this position and get
an interesting position so
if i remember correctly you don't have
to go knight c6
um
people also telling me bishop c5 sort of
potentially transposes to the stafford
i guess
i've never seen this move before i guess
this could transpose to the stafford
shall we try i mean i don't really want
to make the speed run about
you know goading him into some sort of a
gambit
um that's what eric does okay we'll play
bishop c5 i'll play like eric rosen
oh
all right get me out of here this is
ridiculous get me out of here
all right he goes bishop c4 fine i guess
we'll have to play conventionally
but it's okay we'll make this
interesting we'll make this let's punish
him let's punish him
well at this point there's nothing i can
do because now if we castle
and he takes
um there's no more stafford to play he's
already close to castling
so unfortunately we're gonna have to
either go knight c6 and go into the four
knights or we're gonna have to go d6 and
it doesn't really matter which of those
moves we play let's start with d6
to defend the pawn
and
i can load 312. now if we want to spice
things up a little bit if we want to
make it a little bit challenging for him
to develop
how should we proceed in this position
should we go knight c6
conventionally do we have another option
how do we spice add some tabasco sauce
to the position
bishop g4 bishop g4
because if we play knight c6 knowing
this guy's
style he's probably going to go h3
and we're gonna regret it so we got to
squeeze this into in while we have the
window of opportunity he's probably
going to go back to e2 or something d3
okay now we go knight c6 obviously and
now we're threatening knight t4 so this
is a classic line i've had this in blitz
a million times this is still boring as
hell
now in this position there's a couple of
things to understand
knight d4 is possible that's one
possible move
it's not as strong as it is when there's
no bishop on e3 because he can play
bishop takes d4 and preserve his pawn
structure
against players who are very boring how
do you play how do you spice things up
you want to keep the tension the best
thing to do against these kinds of
players
is to let them you know give them some
rope
force them to make decisions so the
classic way
of making
white make the decision here is to drop
the bishop to b6 so that we avoid him
taking on c5 and ruining our pawn
structure
um because if he takes now we play a
takes b6 and those double pawns are not
a big deal we get the a file which is
really good
yeah so you got to make them
make them think make these players think
and you will see i can almost guarantee
you
that he's going to do something either
irrational or he's going to panic okay
so we dropped the bishop to h5 he's
probably going to contemplate g4
uh for a while here
if he plays g4 we have to contemplate a
sacrifice on g4
i don't know if it's the time is right
for that i don't think it is i don't
think we have enough there uh to
sacrifice i think we'll just drop it
goes king h2
now that's a weird looking move i'm not
sure what he's trying to do maybe rook
juwon and g4 something like that that
would be an interesting idea for sure
i'll talk about that after the game guys
so
how should we
proceed what should we do
how do we
what do we do
i think we just castle i don't think
there's a point in uh
in doing anything wild i think we'll
just castle here let's see what he does
let's see how he
orients his pieces here
is queen d2
okay so i see what he was trying to do
i think the reason he put this king on
h2 is that in the event of bishop takes
f3 he plays g takes f3 and his king is
no longer on that open jupa he can then
quickly play rook g1 and try to attack
us down the gpa we've seen this kind of
theme before where even though his pawn
structure technically is ruined he's the
one who gets
he gets a file too
so the question we should ask ourselves
is
does that warrant us not taking on f3
and i would say that the answer to that
is no i think bishop takes f3 creates
such
damage on his king side that assuming
that we can manage the g-file getting
open and assuming that we can manage the
threats along the g-file which i'm sure
we will be able to
uh the weaknesses that he's just created
are permanent so 100 this is a deal that
is worth it as long as we're very
careful we have to be very careful now
we can't you know it's easy to get
checkmated here as well
so
there's two things that have to be
considered the first is that we should
probably try to start king side
operation so moves like knight h5 come
to mind the second thing is that we
should balance that with some
prophylaxis so at some point we don't
have to do this immediately we should
probably consider a move like king hay
but i think the greater priority is for
us to stake a claim on the king side so
that he doesn't run circles over us on
that side of the board so i vote knight
h5 let's
get the wheels turning let's get the
factory running
because as of yet he's not attacking
this pawn he's not threatening anything
there
so we need to be the ones to start
attacking first and i think a lot of
people
are automatically tempted to meet rook
she won with kha that's an instinct
that's a knee jerk reaction he's gone
rook g1 oh he's got a pin let's move the
king away but that one tempo could
potentially be very important against a
skilled attacker
a lot of you want to activate the queen
where should we put it where should we
put the queen should we put it on f6 or
should we put it on h4 where's the queen
accomplishing more think about specifics
on which of these two squares is the
queen actually creating a threat only on
one of them on f6 it's not doing
anything on h4 it's not attacking h3 we
don't have a light scored bishop anymore
you want to make sure the queen is doing
something specific i vote queen f6
okay so he goes rook g4 ignoring the
attack on f3
this guy is legit
i like the way he's playing so he's gone
from very passive to very aggressive in
the snap of a finger
now as the russian expression goes
having said a
you gotta say b so
putting the queen on f6 and then not
taking on f3 well that doesn't seem very
sensible does it let's do it
let's go for it rook g1
um
now the threats against g7 have gotten
serious
now he's doubled his rooks
now we need to take care of this jeep on
because one more move and he's going to
create potentially insurmountable
threats he's already probably thinking
about a sacrifice so we've waited until
the last second
g6 is possible but it doesn't solve the
underlying problem and he could def he
could potentially use this pin to sack
on g6
so now is the time to do what
now is the time to do what
why i don't see why we need to take his
bishop that has nothing to do with it
the problem is the g file
you guys are going at it from the wrong
angle i'll explain this after after the
game go king hd
he ate chain is the better move the
problem would take okay i'll explain it
after the game knight t5 is good this
guy is very legit i'm gonna have to play
a little bit faster here
so
now we need to continue attacking i'm
not too worried about anything that he
can do to us the king is very safe
we need to continue attacking on the
king's side and what's missing on the
king side is a little bit of spice we
need some open files we need something
to join this queen this queen is all
alone
so
we got to go f5
this is very gutsy play by both of us
and
because of the placement of my queen
which is so dominant the knight on h5
which is defending g7 i'm very
optimistic about our attack
but uh the time situation not our friend
so let's see if we can accelerate a
little bit rook takes f5
okay
now potentially we want to triple on the
file knight d4 comes to mind
yeah rook a to f8 is probably going to
be our next move notice how he's managed
to keep the bishops here all the way
throughout the game rook g2 now this
seems like a bit of a
capitulation of his attacking ambitions
i like that he's played that move that
means he doesn't know what to do
um he's also trying to milk our clock
now 97 is protected
okay so
what should we do how should we proceed
do we change our strategy or do we
continue yeah we don't have to change
anything we go rook of fate
uh continuing to accumulate pieces on
the king side okay takes
all right so we'll take i mean you've
got to take see how it took a second
there just to check for intermediate
moves anything i don't see anything
let's take
oh he wants
this oh that's his oh wow that's uh
that's a very advanced idea
which i will fully and
fully admit i missed
we'll have to sack an exchange here
because if we move the rook then he goes
bishop g4
and he wins a piece
that's nice
okay we're going to have to sack an
exchange
we're going to have to stack an exchange
and the way that we have to sack an
exchange is to play knight e7 i'm gonna
have to focus here guys and basically
play silently for the rest of the game
probably
um
because after bishop f5 knight f5 my
worry isn't even the position it's the
clock
my worry is more the clock than the
position so i'm gonna have to focus and
then after the game
after the game i'm going to talk through
uh hopefully you know win or lose my
strategy in this position
okay guys zero accusations tolerated he
literally just found one good idea
i'm capable of missing it so i don't
want to hear it
we will check the game
as you guys know i always check the game
at this point he's playing incredibly
well but
totally have seen 1800s play this well a
million times so
again if you were him you wouldn't want
an entire crowd of people chanting that
he's using stockfish we will check the
game
all right
so
i still think i have a very strong
attack by the way rook g4 and see he's
blundered back so this is a small
blunder what should we do
now i want to put a knight on f3 we have
to try to put a knight on f3
and so in order to do that we take the
rook first then we put a knight on f3
and recapture his queen winning back the
exchange we're going to be up a pawn in
that end game it's not going to be over
that is going to be a very hard end game
for me to win with one minute on the
clock but i'm going to try my best
and then i'm going to do a small lecture
after the game about
you know cheating and stuff
okay so knight f3 knight takes d2
then we're gonna okay he takes with the
bishop
so let's play knight f4 check
centralizing the knight
if he takes it that's a good trade for
us we're up a pawn
and now we have a very nice rook on f4
he's gonna go f3 i guess
okay so let's get our king out we got to
get our king out
yeah but
tone down the cheating and stuff because
i'm always going to check the game
anyway so
if there are suspicions i'm going to
always bring them up
um
okay so let's go h6
yeah so what i'm going to try to do here
is make things go boom on the on the
other side of the board
check the game just means i'm going to
look i'm going to plug the moves into an
engine and
if i find that he played suspiciously i
will let everybody know
but i don't believe he did
he's just very strong i mean there's no
doubt about that
yeah let's go
here oh wow he offers a rook trade wait
let me think
this is uh i mean if this is a draw
then i will be shocked
wait i gotta calculate it take six
yeah let's take it let's take it let's
take it
okay i think oh eclipse
okay we want to go here
this is winning that's it two pass pawns
it's called pants in russian this is
winning
thank you eclipse yeah guys i have like
an hour on my clock this is fine
this is not a problem trust me
this is not a draw we've got two
connected we have got two passers that
are too far away from the king
we just go h3
d3
d2 d1 that's me
this guy was good
congrats that was a good game by this
guy
fatcher chow
100 i'm 99.9 sure it was legit
no stalemate okay so let's go here
notice what i'm doing i'm leaving with a
pawn
i'm leaving him with the pawn and now
we're going to walk around
to this side of the board and checkmate
him
there's no stalemate he still has this
move i don't care see when you're trying
to mate with like a couple seconds make
sure you're leaving him with pawn moves
that way you don't have to worry about
stalemate if you know he's got a bunch
of pawn moves you know that the game is
going to be over
you know there's gonna be no stalemate
nice
i can check the accuracy but it doesn't
really indicate much my accuracy was
probably pretty low
uh given that i missed that idea
but we'll see
okay 90 so 78.6 to 90.5 which is which
is reasonable but uh not not amazing
um
so
i want to say a couple of things i've
said i've talked about this before i
know that very few people actually were
like accusing him and stuff so i'm not
going to pretend that everybody was
uh jumped to the conclusion i will also
take a little bit of the blame when i
say
i think when people see that i've missed
something the automatic suspicion is
well this guy's 1800 how can an 1800 see
something that i missed
and the reality is that it is very rare
for me to miss something or a tactical
sequence than an 1800 saw but it happens
and i think that's one of the good
things about chess it totally happens
um i'm human i don't look at everything
i'm also talking about the game as i'm
playing it
um this guy might be familiar with this
idea from another game
so
if you were this guy
you don't want to get into a situation
where weaker players are afraid of
playing good moves because they're
afraid that they're going to get accused
that's a situation that's even worse
than a lot of people cheating
thank you oh eclipse i appreciate it
now at this point some people will say
well let's be real when you're playing
blitz you get
salty at certain fms and ims who play
incredibly well and i do
um and i'm not always
plugging the games in before i'm kind of
hinting that something is amiss i admit
that
but you know that's
that's a little bit different so
um
you know i if i if i'm saying that i'm i
genuinely believe that i'm suspicious
even if i'm wrong and even if i
shouldn't do that as much i've tried to
do that less
but with these 18 18 1900s you really
never know
um
okay
so let's take a look at the game and
then we'll move on to some blitz
um
i've been accused of cheating many times
on my various different accounts it's
not a good feeling
it's scary when a top player accuses you
of cheating and you actually didn't
cheat because you know that they have
authority and weight so
um but but with chess.com they check
everything independently they're not
subject to the influence of some player
who
throws the fit and says i'm not gonna
play anymore if this guy's not banned
also 1800s are good
all right so knight c3 unfortunately he
didn't play into the staffer that was
the real problem that's why i want to
ban him not because he not because of
some purported accusation but because he
didn't go into the staffer that's
actually the reason to ban him
um
so bishop c5 i mean the other way to
spice this up is to go d5 and transpose
into the elephant gambit
after he takes d5 and bishop d6 this is
the elephant gambit
which is interesting now if he goes 95 i
guess eric's idea is to go knight c6 and
again offer a transition into the
stafford
with knight c3 bishop c5 which are the
main moves
i guess in this position white could
play knight f3 um i think that's the
downside of this move order and trying
to go d4 quickly but after castles d4
bishop b4 i mean i guess this is okay
for black
so i'm sure eric has analyzed this
all right
so bishop c4 d6 castles
and i guess that if i were white i would
start with h3 uh just to stop bishop g4
although it doesn't really impact the
evaluation d3 knight c6
um eric rosen bishop e3 is important
now there's a lot of misunderstanding
okay bishop b6 h3 bishop h5
if he had played g4 there's a lot of
people who think that every time this
happens you should sack that's not true
sacking on g4 is exceedingly dangerous
uh but for both sides particularly for
the side that's doing the sacking
because
if you look at this position
you might think well we have two pawns
for the piece the king is wide open
queen is coming out to f6 that's all
true black's got undeniable compensation
here but it's often not as simple as it
looks because why can bring the king up
to g2 in order to lend more support to
this knight
and if black plays queen f6
well then you have to reckon with knight
d5 that's a nasty little move
also white could go rook h1 trying to
pave the way for a king evacuation even
better would be to go rogue g1 because
if black goes queen g6 trying to x-ray
you go king f1 and then you x-ray the
bishop back and at this point the
compensation starts to fizzle out so you
got to be careful about these sacks
this is unclear i'm not sure what i
would have done here
um
so bishop yeah so he plays king h2 which
is a weird move
but it was an interesting concept so
he's luring me into doing this
and this is far from a simple position
because again we've ruined his pawn
structure but now he gets the g file for
a potential attack
um
yeah the banning is done purely on fair
play system that is true
so don't worry
if if like you got accused by somebody
and you didn't cheat
now if you did cheat and i'm sure that
there are
among the 4 000 people watching
somebody's cheated in the past
i mean i think that
the best thing to do is to always i mean
this is useless for me to say but it's
to confess um
and and get a second chance from
chess.com
uh and the situation would be greatly
improved if people developed more people
developed a conscience but
that's uh that's just the reality on the
ground there are cheaters among us yes
exactly
now i think another thing to realize the
last thing i'll say on this topic the
last thing i'll say on this topic before
i move on
is that
if you've been
uh if your account has been closed or
you've been accused by admins
i think the natural reaction is to and
you truly didn't cheat i think the
natural thing is to be that happens
exceedingly rarely almost never
uh and you can trust me on this but if
it does happen
this sort of tawa kipa situation
you've got to be careful about getting
angry at chess.com because it's not a
person or a nefarious people sitting
around here that's ben
bob 111
it's like a complete algorithm it's just
a machine that's basically assigning a
value
there's no human that's sitting behind
the scenes just like
uh
laughing a
witch laugh and then trying to like get
people banned so
it happens sometimes and uh i think we
would be better served if people are
also
less emotionally tied into that although
i get that it can be
very annoying
uh although it almost never happens
so knight h5 i can't give you all the
information about this i'm obviously
some of it is
not uh it's classified but obviously a
lot of it is
uh conducted through a
digital through a computer process
obviously
um
and obviously there are humans who are
managing this process and who are
involved but a lot of it is
is machine based so rook g1 and queen f6
now a lot of you wanted to go queen h4
this would be a bad move
uh for two reasons the first is that the
queen doesn't really do anything the
second is that the queen is very easy to
attack and we've talked about this
before
i've written an old chess.com article
called queen the supporting actress
and i attribute that to yasser and
yasser
uh when i trained with him a couple of
years ago he would always call the queen
the supporting actress in an attack when
it's the lead actress it can be easy to
chase away and so the queen becomes a
huge vulnerability so putting it on h4
here is a great example of that you
don't want the queen on the front lines
because then you're gonna have to keep
worrying about the queen getting
attacked
but
um
when you put the queen on f6 it's a
little bit behind the scenes and it's
doing more it's attacking f3 a sniper
bishop g5 does not trap the queen
in this case either because the queen
takes f2 check so no it there's no way
to trap the queen to my understanding
but um but it comes very close so that's
another reason to be careful
okay
and you guys can search up my article on
chess.com which was written basically in
yasser's honor
and uh okay so he plays rook g4 he sacks
upon and doubles his rooks
and we drop the king to h8 and i guess
after knight d5 this was a mistake i
mean i guess in retrospect we shouldn't
have played f5
um according to the engine no f5 is good
according to the engine
believe it or not
yeah so according to the engine this is
the mistake
and that's why he played rook g2 so that
was a genius move because if he would
have taken and gone bishop e6 here
uh rook f6 and he can't go to g4 so
that's the whole point i didn't ask
myself what he wanted
you see that was the mistake that i made
i didn't practice what i preached i
didn't ask myself what does he want to
accomplish and then i probably would
have noticed that the g4 square is wide
open
uh so what should i have done knight d4
is the best move again i'm turn the
engine on so
and after knight takes b6 ab6
the square is defended
uh the knight wants to even potentially
go to e2 and then to f4 like this
and if he takes it
and now goes bishop e6 then we have rook
f6 bishop g4 in this final position
can somebody tell me what the difference
is why doesn't this win a knight uh what
has changed in the position
i was wrong no i was wrong i i miss i
was too cocky
i didn't ask myself but the thread was
either queen d5 or queen of four but
this is crushing because rook g3 or k2
is crushing
now i don't think i said he doesn't know
what he's doing i think i think i said
he doesn't know what to do which is a
small difference uh but i was wrong he
didn't know what to do
so i played rook afe this is a good
lesson and never forgetting to ask
yourself the golden question so this
loses an exchange and it's all because
this bishop on e3 is still alive you
cannot go queen f4
um
and that's a brilliant idea
and that that also is the best mode
okay um so knight d4 was also a pretty
natural move i'd say um knight f4 is
probably well now it leaves the g7 pawn
hanging so
i and also rook g3 basically almost
traps the queen so i'd say this is a
little bit i'd be more skeptical about
this
all right
okay f8
knight b6 ab6 bishop b6 and to my credit
knight e7 is the best movement black
retains an advantage according to the
engine black is still all this is equal
slash tiny bit better for black
this is still quite a bit better for
black
and the reason why is that the king is
still very weak
i still have a pawn for the exchange
remember that
and
black still has a ton of pieces in the
attack so what this is another good
lesson that when you blunder you don't
panic and go crazy
you try to minimize your losses
uh you try to minimize your losses
so a good example of panicking would be
i don't know something like well work at
four would be probably okay
but dropping the rook back stubbornly
and saying well i can't do anything so
i'm just going to go down the line
well that would be a good example of
something not to do
whereas asking yourself how can i
minimize the losses oh i can just give
up the exchange
and while i'm at it i can at least
involve the knight in the attack that
gives you wins uh in these unfortunate
situations thank you big macs and reggae
potatoes for the prime
rook g5 knight h4
and rook g4 is the blunder that allows
me to transition into a winning end game
his best move the only move would have
been queen before hard to find this is
basically an engine move trying to
attack the knight from a distance
and after knight f4 rook g3 amazingly he
somehow holds on here still it's an
incredibly sharp position black's got an
attack
according to the computer the eval is
equal
um i'm not going to pretend that i know
why
or actually you have to go with it with
this rook
queen c6 and somehow queen e4 but you
guys can see how difficult this would
have all been to find
so
only move was queen before
rook g4 takes takes knight f3 and
white has a certain amount of drawing
chances here i don't want to analyze
this too carefully
because yeah black is of a pawn we have
a much more active rook than white
um i will so i will only explain how i
calculated the pawn end game
because the you know what i did here was
pretty simple i bring my king into the
game
then i push my pawns up i want to go
before at some point
to try to make inroads on the queen side
and so the only interesting moment was
here how did i decide to take the rook
so
first of all my intuition told me that
this should be good because i'm up a
pawn
okay that's number one but that wasn't
the main thing
there are i would say and i'm pulling
this out of my butt a little bit but in
such situations there are three main
factors to consider
other than material so material is the
obvious factor apart from that when
you're considering a transition into a
pod end game there's three things to
consider
the first is who's got more and the most
important thing who's got more potential
to create past pawns
um
and
as a sub bullet point of those
potential past bond creating ideas who
can create outside pass bonds pass bonds
that are that are literally apart from
all of the other pawns
so that's number one number two who's
got the better king activity is either
side is one of the sides
far superior in terms of king activity
like this is one king dominating over
the other
and number three which doesn't really
apply here
is um
well i guess we can lump that into
number two i was going to say extra pawn
move so who's got more pawn moves in
reserve
that can help create zugsvan
and number three is pawn breakthroughs
so which side has more possibilities of
breaking through
and upon breakthrough doesn't
necessarily create a past fun
uh it can also allow your king to make
inroads into your opponent's territory
so
let's apply those concepts now the first
who's got more great potential to create
a past pawn well only one side has the
potential to create a passer and that is
black and this is true after either fe4
or d4 who can tell me
how i was able to determine that where
is this potential pass pawn creatable
not the d file guys g6h5
so the most clinical way to win this
position would be the very classic plan
you create an outside passer you force
white king
to supervise and babysit that passer and
while it's doing so you're using it as a
decoy walking your king up and taking
your opponent's pawns how should white
black do that
if you play impatiently if you start
with g6 then you slightly violate the
second roll you give white superior king
activity and then it's going to be a
little bit harder to create hbo to get
h5 and this is still winning uh but you
have to do some extra work
how should we avoid this how should
black avoid giving white this move king
h4 what should we do first
this is simple
king g5 yeah king g5 white can't really
do anything because the pawn structure
is pretty symmetrical these double pawns
are actually kind of good
because even if
white gets rid of the b pawn you have
the b7 pawn which is potentially
stopping the progress of the other pawns
so white has to go back and forth h5
and that's it the game is over because
okay the moment white let's gives you
the opportunity you walk in
if not you literally just push the pawn
then you go king f14 e3 and you vacuum
up all the pawns this is easy
and this is i would say one of the
classical methods of winning such end
games
so
that was pretty easy to calculate
now i could have done the same thing
after d takes e4 i could have gone king
h5 g6 h5 but here i decided on an
alternate method i want king e6
because applying bullet point number
three pawn breaks who's got the pawn
brakes only one side black's got the
pawn break d5
that either
leads to the creation of another pass
pawn with d4
or after ed5 king d5 allows black to
make inroads towards white's queen side
after king h4 there was an important
moment
rather than playing d5 and rushing i
asked myself what my opponent wanted and
he wants to go king h5 so you don't give
him any king activity you play g6
locking the king on h4 you've got to go
back
he played g5 which made the situation
worse he helped me create a pass spawn
um
but even if he didn't do that i would
have gone d5
and in this case i would have gone to c4
and taken all of his pawns there
if he goes b3 how should black proceed
how should black proceed in this
position
and there are many ways of winning this
many ways
you can play either e4 now a lot of you
guys are saying c4 but then he goes b4
forward he keeps things locked up
so the first way is to is to break
through with e4
and again to create two pass pawns and
the king is overwhelmed but the thematic
move is b4
basically sacrificing a pawn
then if you want you can fix the pawns
and preemptively push your own pawn out
then go king d4 king c3 and collect his
other pawns there's nothing he can do if
he plays f4 you'll take it
and then when the moment is right
you will go h5
forcing the liquidation of these puns or
if he goes g5 then
that's it then he's tied down to the
defensive h5 pawn
so
that's a classic pawn break how did i
see that well i know that my king needs
to go up to d4 that's the key square
so you're forcing the c3 pawn off the
board
uh and by keeping at least one pawn you
are guaranteeing that once you take the
rest of white's pawns you're gonna have
a pass pawn
so it doesn't matter how many pawns your
opponent has in such situations as long
as you ensure that you have at least one
pawn left
so in the game h5 g5 i play d5 you want
king f2 he made it easy for me because
now you have what's called trousers
russian basically two pant legs um
you know and and the king is overwhelmed
does the engine say black is winning on
the rook trade i'm sure it will
uh if we turn on the engine yeah rook
trade is like it's saying minus four
right now but it's gonna it's gonna go
up
yeah this is winning
yeah this is completely winning and
there's many ways to win here you can go
king g5 you could go c4 first you could
fix everything and then go king g5 and
g6
so as long as you know the overall plan
and you're not sloppy
um you know and when i say sloppy what
do i mean i mean giving your opponent's
king unnecessary activity as long as you
avoid that
uh you'll be in pretty good shape
there's a lot of calculation to do in
pawn end games i can give you some pawn
end games that are insanely complicated
and like there's a million things going
on there are some beautiful pawn end
games out there
that are not very well known
um i can show you one of them but you
know i want to play some blitz also so
um
so that basically concludes this game
and obviously like he played until
checkmate
he played until checkmate but there's
nothing to see here
okay we had questions
after bishop e6 can you show why knight
if knight f4 doesn't work sure
so after he played bishop e6 that deadly
move which i missed
knight f4 he plays
bishop takes f4
he doesn't take well he could also take
my rook here but then you take his rook
um but after bishop f4 rook f4 he can
play rook takes g7
and there's a beautiful detail guys
in this position in this position
white to play
this is amazing because it looks like
black and force the queen trade black is
okay
but white has an incredible move here
i mean there's not that many things
available you can drop your king to h1
no no white's king is in check
don't get ahead of yourself but why can
go king h1 preserving the queens
and if queen takes d2 then rook g8 so
never make assumptions in such positions
um black has to play queen f3 but then
you can play queen g2
and use this rook to hide the king
and in addition to rook g8 which is a
mate threat white's threatening rook
takes c7 so
this would have been bad for black so
this is a complicated line and knight f4
would have been possible
um so um
so any other questions
let me see
how did you identify that d4 was the key
square well when did i do that
um
oh and i did the pawn sack
oh yeah when i was talking about b4
when i was talking about the beef when i
was talking about b4
um how did oh because well because it's
just the only way forward
um there's no rocket science here i just
understand that i need to walk my king
to the queen side
um i just i understand that i need to
walk my king to the queen side
you can make an argument that c4 is the
critical square but you can't get rid of
this pawn if i had a pawn on a5 then c4
would have been the critical square i
would have gone a4
since i don't have the pawn on a5
i only have the tools necessary to get
rid of this pawn not the other one
um
so uh the key square is determined by
by where you can break through that's
all there is to it um it's there's no
like rules for determining it
may you sacrifice on g4 in a game
against gm well if i get the opportunity
to then i will but i can't guarantee it
any final questions
and then we'll move to blitz
how bothersome with him playing bishop
g5 instead of bishop e3b
not bothersome at all i would have gone
h6
and then or actually knight t4 i mean i
i just would have gotten knight d4 and
by doing it before him i also uncastled
so if he does the same thing
then i don't have to castle short i can
use the g file much like he did i can
use the g file for the attack
you can use the g file for the attack
so this would be pretty devastating
and um
that's about it
all right
bishop c5 takes e3 would open up the f
file for him i don't like doing that it
also takes control of the d4 square i
want to make sure that the knight has
access to it
all right
okay guys so we'll pause the speed run
for today go back to some blitz
um
hope you guys enjoyed these are some
very fun games thanks everybody for the
support
[Music]